estamos en la página 285 y vamos con el
problema 87 en el problema 87 nos dice
que a un empleado se le paga 1.5 veces
su salario normal por trabajar en horas
extra más allá de las 40 horas
excluyendo los domingos ok entonces
vamos a ponerle 1.5 veces más
en horas extra horas extra
que no sea un domingo no domingo domingo
y además son horas extras después de las
40 horas vale horas extra va y en
domingo y en domingo se le paga el doble
entonces se le paga dos veces más el
doble pues éste cuando trabaja en
domingo por horas
domingo 2 domingo muy bien y lo que
queremos saber es cuánto se le pagó al
empleado la semana pasada entonces y
pago
de la semana pasada vale bueno vamos a
ver qué nos dan como opciones de
información en el 1 nos dice que el pago
regular es de 10 dólares por hora
entonces pago
pago regular regular es de 10 dólares
por hora bueno con esto tenemos un poco
de información verdad tenemos que las
horas extras las horas extra que no sean
en domingo es 15 por la información de
aquí arriba entonces le voy a poner
horas extra que no sean domingo y que
las horas en domingo son de a 20 d a 20
dólares entonces le voy a poner de de
domingo pero esto todavía no nos dice
cuánto trabajo el empleado entonces no
podemos saber cuánto ganó en la semana
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 nos dicen que la semana pasada
el empleado trabajo
un total de 54 horas entonces trabajó 54
horas pero ningún día trabajó más de 8
ningún día ningún día
más de 8 más de 8
si queremos responder el pago si
queremos tener la esperanza de poder
conocerlo hay que juntarlo con el inciso
1 verdad es el único lugar donde hablan
de cantidades pero ahora el inciso 2
todavía no nos ayuda a completar la
información que necesitamos porque nos
dice que que trabajó 54 horas en la
semana y que ningún día fue más de 8
pero no sabemos cómo están repartidas
esas horas en los días de la semana y si
es importante cuánto trabajo el domingo
verdad no sé a lo mejor puede ser que de
lunes a sábado trabajo 8 horas entonces
lleva 48 de lunes a sábado y luego puede
ser que en domingo haya completado las
otras 66 en domingo entonces esa es una
posibilidad o puede ser que todos los
días haya trabajado lo mismo entonces a
lo mejor tenemos que que no se me parece
que todos los días trabajan siete horas
con cinco céntimos de hora eso dan siete
por siete es 49 49 5 es 54 a hat
entonces puede ser que haya trabajado
o así y nos daría diferentes cantidades
porque las del domingo se pagan más vale
entonces no sabemos realmente cuánto hay
que pagarle porque no sabemos cuánto
trabajo en domingo hay muchísimas
posibilidades bueno entonces ni siquiera
juntando las dos podemos responder
entonces la respuesta sería y muy bien
ahora vamos a el problema 88 en el
problema 88 nos dice que un teatro
vendió ciertos boletos ok y la cantidad
de boletos que vendió fue 400 sólo que
algunos los vendió en precio regular y
otros los vendió con descuento bueno y
lo que queremos saber es cuánto gano
cuánto gano cuánto gano muy bien vamos a
ver qué opciones de información nos dan
en la 1 nos dice que la cantidad de
tickets o de boletos vendidos a precio
completo fue una cuarta parte de los que
tenían descuento entonces vamos a
ponerle sea los completos idea los de
descuento entonces la cantidad de
tickets completos fue una cuarta parte
de los de descuento en una cuarta parte
de los de descuento bueno pues esto
todavía no nos dice cuánto ganó porque
ni siquiera habla de dinero verdad vamos
a ver si eso lo podemos juntar con la
información 2 aquí nos dice que el
precio de un boleto completo precio de
completo
este completo fue 25 fue 25 25 dólares
me imagino bueno pues esto tampoco nos
dice la información que necesitamos
verdad tenemos el precio de un boleto
completo pero no sabemos el precio de un
boleto con descuento entonces aunque
sepamos relacionar dieuzeide y
conozcamos exactamente cuánto cuánto es
por ejemplo esto estos 400 que se
vendieron fueron semanas de entonces
aunque podamos conocerse y de iu
conozcamos el precio de los completos
pues no vamos a poder decir la ganancia
si no conocemos el precio de los de
descuento entonces juntando estas dos no
podemos responder la pregunta y entonces
la respuesta sería y vale bueno vamos
ahora al problema
89 déjame hacerlo en color blanco que
casi nunca lo hago en el problema 89 nos
dice que bolita representa una de las
operaciones más menos o por ok esto se
ve interesante bolita
más menos o por
o por ok entonces lo que nos piden
determinar es si esto se cumple para
todos los números k r&m si se cumple que
cada
bolita bolita l m l + m es igual a cada
bolita el mas k bolita m va esto suena
padre nos están preguntando si podemos
concluir que se cumple la propiedad
distributiva con respecto a la suma vale
entonces de más menos y por cuál es la
satisface pues nada más por verdad si le
ponemos más no se cumple esto si le
ponemos menos no se cumple esto entonces
nos están preguntando básicamente si
bolita es la operación por ba bueno
vamos a ver qué opciones nos dan opción
1 en la opción 1 nos dice que cada
bolita 1
es distinto a una bolita acá para
para algunos
algunos números números acá ok lo que
nos están diciendo aquí es básicamente
que bolita bolita no es no es ni más ni
por saleh o sea que bolita es menos
porque si bolita fuera más o por como
como multiplicar y sumar con mutan pues
no podríamos tener esto acá más uno
siempre es uno más acá acá por uno
siempre es uno por acá entonces no puede
suceder que éstos sean distintos si es
más o por y entonces lo que nos dice el
inciso 1 es que la operación es menos
vale entonces si podemos responder esta
pregunta bolita es por no bolita no es
por vale entonces ojo no tenemos que
concluir que la respuesta a esto sea así
lo único que tenemos que hacer es ver si
la información de este inciso nos
permite responder esta pregunta y si nos
permite responderla negativamente vale
entonces tenemos que éste por sí mismo
es suficiente vamos al inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 nos dice bolita es
ok si bolitas resta pues otra vez
volibol y te resta abuelita no es por
entonces como habilitando es
multiplicación podemos responder esta
pregunta entonces esta también es
suficiente para responder entonces la
respuesta sería de cualquiera de los dos
cualquiera de los dos pedazos de
información nos permite responder si se
da esta igualdad siempre bueno ahora
vamos al problema 90
problema 90 color naranja problema 90
nos pregunta cuántos de los 60 carros
que se vendieron el mes pasado en cierta
distribuidora no tenían ni ventanas
automáticas ni estéreo
estas son muchas negaciones bueno
entonces queremos ver cuántos
cuántos de 60 no tenían tenían
ni ventanas automáticas le voy a poner
así ventanas automáticas mi estéreo
estéreo
entonces qué información tenemos uno nos
dicen que de los 60 carros 20 tenían
exterior pero no ventanas automáticas
entonces 20 con estéreo
sin ventanas automáticas y en el inciso
2 nos dicen que que 30 tenían estéreo
con estéreo
y con ventanas automáticas y ventanas
automáticas ok entonces yo creo que
conviene aquí hacer un diagrama déjame
pintar por aquí en color azul todos los
carros que se vendieron entonces este es
el conjunto de los 60 carros que se
vendieron y aquí dentro de este conjunto
hay algunos que tenían ventanas
automáticas lo voy a pintar un poco más
a la izquierda hay unos que tenían
ventanas automáticas y hay otros que
tenían estéreo en color morado digamos
estos de acá
tenían exterior vale entonces los que
están fuera de este no tenían ventanas
automáticas los que están fuera de este
no tenían estéreo vamos a ver qué
información es esto o sea lo que lo que
nos piden es cuáles son los carros que
están aquí afuera verdad déjame marcarlo
sea lo que queremos son estos de acá sin
ese color esta red estos de acá
bueno no es mucho mejor pero está bien
entonces queremos determinar cuáles son
los coches que están ahí y qué
información nos dan en el inciso 1 nos
dice que hay 20 con estéreo sin ventanas
automáticas los que tienen estéreo son
los de acá y los que no tienen ventanas
automáticas son los de acá sale entonces
nos están diciendo lo voy a poner con
este color amarillo es que aquí hay 20
en esta región de acá hay 20 y luego nos
dice que hay 30 con estéreo y con
ventanas automáticas entonces con
estéreo son estos de acá con ventanas
automáticas son estos de acá estos 30
bueno conociendo la información 1 no
podemos saber nada del azul conociendo
lados
tampoco podemos saber nada de él
y conociendo ambas tampoco simplemente
sabemos que 20 más 30 o sea que los que
tienen estéreo en total son 50 pero
luego de los 10 restantes pues no
sabemos nada acerca de si tienen
ventanas o no no tenemos información
suficiente para responder entonces ni
siquiera juntando estas dos podemos
responder y por lo tanto la respuesta
sería y la respuesta de esta pregunta
vale o vaya de este de este inciso del
jemad bueno entonces aquí no podemos
saber a lo mejor si nos preguntaran otra
cosa si pudiéramos responder por ejemplo
la cantidad de autos que tienen estéreo
o la cantidad de autos que no tienen
estéreo pero lo que nos están pidiendo
no podemos responder lo bueno les
seguimos en los siguientes vídeos con
este examen del gym matters